he's a businessman investor and is
involved in over 400 companies he takes
on big companies breaks the rules and
likes to go after world records he's
worth an estimated four point nine
billion dollars he's Richard Branson and
he is top ten rules for success I mean I
am dyslexic and and therefore I think
I've been very good at keeping things
simple because you know as a dyslexic I
need to need things to be simple for
myself and therefore Virgen I think you
know when we launch a financial service
company or a bank you know we do not use
jargon it's everything is very clear-cut
very simple and and I think people you
know people have an affinity to the
Virgin brand because we don't you know
we don't talk above them or talk down to
them I mean I think a lot of people do
not have the courage to try to start a
business and all I was saying I've
written a book called screw it just do
it and and it basically is trying to say
to people just give it a try actually
sometimes a very very small amount of
money is all that's needed to start a
company I mean my mother found a
bracelet on the street and she handed
into the police station and after three
months the police there to sell it and
you know the the couple of hundred
dollars was really critical at a
critical time in the development of our
business so it's always safe just give
it give it a go and good luck on that
one I think the most important the most
important thing about running a company
is to remember all the time what a
company is a company is simply a group
of people and as a leader of people you
have to be a great listener and you have
to be a great motivator you have to be
very good at praising and looking for
the best in people and you know people
are no different from from flowers if
you water flowers they flourish if you
praise people they flourish and
and that's a critical attribute of an of
a leader you know there is there's a
very thin dividing line between success
and failure when you start a business
from scratch and you know if you don't
have enough money to pay the bills you
go the wrong side of that dividing line
and if you can somehow get enough money
to pay the bills
you stay the right side of that dividing
line you know I've always been running
running running faster than perhaps I
shouldn't and I've have great difficulty
saying no to things so keep on taking on
new things and we've just managed to
stay the right side of the dividing line
over the last 50 years in business but
but equally in those early days when you
when you're starting a business without
any financial backing it's it's easy to
slip the wrong side and in fact you know
most entrepreneurs do do slip the wrong
side and report the important thing is
then just to pick yourself up and you
know start again and if it doesn't work
at that time keep keep going until you
do succeed and not to give up I think
the next stage is you know is to be a
great delegator and not try to do
everything yourself try to find people
who are better than you all the time try
to find people are better than you to
put you put you out of business
effectively so you know whatever you're
spending all your day doing try to find
someone who's better than you to do that
to replace you at it so that you know
you can go off and you know think about
the next big picture you know an
entrepreneur is not a man I'm not a
manager I mean an entrepreneur somebody
who is great at conceiving ideas
starting and starting ideas built
building ideas but then handing over to
really good managers to manage the
businesses you know the moment you've
got more than one business you can't be
hands-on doing everything I don't
actually think with the stereo a
stereotype of a business person trading
all over people to get to the top
generally speaking works I think if you
treat people well people will come back
and and come back for more and it's a
very small world I actually think that
the
the bet the best wave of becoming a
successful business leader is is is
dealing with people you know fairly and
and well and like to think that's how
how we run virgin I love learning and
I've never actually thought I was you
know starting a company as such and I
just saw situations as I traveled in
life where I felt I could improve on the
way things were being done by other
people so and you know so I would you
know what what do I favorite phrases is
screw it let's do it and I've used that
phrase a lot of times and we and and
we've you know we just love going in and
trying to shake up industries and doing
it better than it's been done before
yeah when we launched Virgin Atlantic 30
years ago the New York Times did a
review and they did some market research
and they said you know first of all with
a name like virgin it's not going to go
the whole way but but but sec but
secondly that and they did market
research which said only 7% of people
would fly on an airline called virgin
and and we put our hands up and said 7%
would be just fine so so we carried on
with it but there were a lot of there
were a lot of skeptics out there and
there always will be lots of skeptics
when when you want to start something
new everybody will tell you why it's a
bad idea why you shouldn't do it why
you'll you don't lose everything you've
got and in the end you just got to get
out and try to prove them wrong
but good luck I think the word business
it becomes the business but what you're
doing is you're you're you know painting
a picture you're you're trying to and
you're trying to create create something
to make a difference to other people's
lives you have a blank canvas and you're
filling in in every little bit of that
canvas to get every single little detail
right and and and if that canvas you
know sings out at you at the end and
it's you know it's a beautiful picture
your your business going to be
successful if you know if bits of the
canvas are not quite right your business
may fail so if you set up to change
people's lives you
got to get every single little detail
right you got to make sure that the
people that you're working with 100%
believe in what you're trying to do and
you've got you've got to make sure that
what you're trying to do is worthwhile
spending your time on and at the end of
the day you want to be sure that you
know that the people's lives you've
affected you've really been effective
them and benefited them and you know if
you get all that right and you know
hopefully you'll be able to pay the
bills at the end of the year I would say
the overarching and key thing that
really binds the group together is the
idea of not just playing the game but
changing it for good
I think Richard embodies the principles
better than anyone I've ever worked with
in anybody that I know because he's very
focused on business on starting new
businesses on making sure that you've
got the right people in the businesses
but also on doing things differently and
really changing the game and I think
that it's the combination of those that
sits in a part is the great entrepreneur
of his generation thank you guys for
watching I made this video because
Arlene Dee asked me to so if there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do I'd
also love to know which of Richard
branches top-10 rules you like the most
leave it in the comments and I'm going
to join in the discussion thank you so
much for watching
continue to believe and we'll see you
soon